one hundred dollars in Bitcoin will be
distributed to every undergraduate ute
at MIT this fall it's a giant social
experiment spearheaded by to MIT
students Jeremy Rubin a sophomore
studying computer science and an elder
founder and president of the MIT Bitcoin
Club and first year in the MBA program
as well gentlemen thanks for joining us
so what's your best case scenario here
distributing Bitcoin to every undergrad
yeah hi thanks for having us on best
case scenario we want to see people
building awesome things and furthering
the role of Bitcoin in the world we
think that you know mi key is a great
place to be writing an experiment like
this it's a constant Bennett innovation
and so you know we're just excited to
see what's gonna come out of this dan
what are you gonna do with your Bitcoin
well actually because I'm a graduate
student i'm not getting bitcoin through
this experiment where we're only
targeting undergrads at this point and i
mean this is the goal here to just make
people aware or to see what they do with
it to convert the faithful I mean what
what really is the goal here yeah so
Bitcoin isn't really too much of a well
at least until yesterday a hot topic at
MIT and so we really think that it's a
little bit of a shame and MIT should
really be you know focusing on this and
should be you know the center of the
Bitcoin world and so that's what we're
hoping to accomplish here hey scarlet my
question these two guys are they girl
magnets I mean are they guy magnets
because they're in the Bitcoin Club MIT
that question I mean I mean what a way
to meet girls that's unreal Joe Jeremy
how's it Bitcoin Club how's that working
out guys haha well no my fiancé is a
pretty intimate your fiance's all over
the bit yeah yeah I want to i'm
wandering down points no complaints
sorry I wonder though what kind of
demand is there from the student body at
MIT for Bitcoin or for use of Bitcoin of
me is it a topic of conversation that
you're trying to get started or were
there / collations of it already yeah
there's already some conversation going
on in campus we got the MIT Bitcoin Club
kicked off back in jan you
but we really want to make it more of a
focus get people more educated all the
events we've done so far there's a mix
of a few people who really understand
Bitcoin and then a lot of people who are
just approaching it for the first time
they're very curious but they start at
the point of what is Bitcoin and so we
really want to educate people and really
elevate the conversation hey Jeremy
education is one thing but
practicalities and other China has
effectively made it illegal to transact
a bitcoin as has Russia so so beyond
education how do you actually get people
to trust this thing in the way that
sovereign countries have it well I think
as you know a leading engineering
institution MIT is you know kind of king
of practicality and so that's part of
the experiment is you know seeing what
real world applications we can build
that people will end up trusting such as
so you know there's a number of things
that we could do that it would be very
important for example you could build
sort of a decentralized Kickstarter type
thing for you know crowdfunding you
could start a micro payments solution
which would be you know a boon for you
know news media in terms of you know
online newspapers having a solution for
you know right for their content guys
I'm curious if any if any professors at
MIT torn you to shreds on this so they
look at the theory of Bitcoin forget
about the efficiency but the theory and
say the Bitcoin Club has got it wrong I
would say that most professors are
pretty excited about this project and
seeing where it goes there are certainly
plenty of professors who have questions
about it most of the questions that
we've heard tend to come from the
economic side I think people who
understand the code that technical
aspect of Bitcoin are all pretty
enthusiastic about it as a agent major
innovation and pushing forward what we
can do with technology well Jeremy Rubin
and analytic up at MIT guys I'm sorry to
cut you off we're out of time but
fascinating conversation good luck with
it all right thank you so much you're so
cute there you guys it's immoral MIT
those guys are scary I've got 900 zero
SATs thank you